ce à quoi donner des frissons dans le
dos en un an le nombre d'exécutions a
grimpé de 54% dans le monde à eux seuls
le pakistan l'arabie saoudite et l'iran
sont responsables de 90 % des mises à
morts enregistrés maintenant il ya à peu
près d'un personnes tué par le
gouvernement d'iran chaque jour l'iran
et l'arabie saoudite deux pays où les
questions des droits de la personne ne
cesse de hanter le gouvernement canadien
en toile de fond la reprise du dialogue
avec l'iran et la vente de blindés en
arabie saoudite le canada certainement à
doit envoyer un message plus fort
regardez en arabie saoudite nous sommes
présents et des exécutions augmente en
iran nous ne sommes pas présents
les exécutions augmente devant les
critiques le gouvernement insiste miser
sur les liens diplomatiques et la clé
donc nous on va s'efforcer d'être à la
fois très franc et très direct avec ces
pays là et avec eux c'est gouvernement
là mais en même temps d'être présent
pour essayer de trouver des poignets au
sein de ces sociétés là pour les faire
évoluer et le gouvernement ne veut
surtout pas envoyé de message flou au
sujet de la peine de mort sous les
conservateurs les demandes de clémence
pour les canadiens n'étaient plus
systématique
il était formulée à la pièce en fonction
des cas fini cas par cas au canada est
contre la peine de mort ne se meut sur
le pays abolitionniste ira dire partout
en toutes circonstances plus de 1400
canadiens étaient emprisonnés dans le
monde le mois dernier pour des raisons
de confidentialité le gouvernement ne
veut ni divulgué combien d'entre eux
sont condamnés à mort ni dans quel pays
ils sont détenus
il se contente de dire qu'ils sont très
peu nombreux
le cas le plus connu est celui de roanne
hausse mais un albertain toujours
condamné à mort au montana pour le
meurtre de deux autochtones
le refus du gouvernement harper de
demander la clémence du canadien avait
rompu avec une vieille tradition
maintenant nous espérons qu'il y aura un
autre demande à
pour monsieur semaine avec cette
nouvelle politique avec un changement
politique le gouvernement veut se faire
rassurant mais le rapport d'amnesty
donne des arguments à ceux qui remettent
en question son approche face à des pays
comme l'iran et l'arabie saoudite ici
marc godbout radio canada ottawa